ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูนิสวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคน
ในช่องที่สุดไม่งั้นเดี๋ยวคุณนี้เจอหรือ
ลืมนักเรียน
อะไรค่ะสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกๆคนนะคะอ่า
เดี๋ยววิ่ง Share  screen แป๊บนึงนะคะ
หน้ามาแล้วเนาะเดี๋ยวดูสิว่าเอาเส้นใหญ่ๆ
นะคะคุณนิวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันนี้วัน
พุธครับค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 8 ครับเดือนอะไร
คะเดือน
มิถุนายนครับปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 กับสระปีคศพี่ไปขาปีคศ 2
022 ขับปะสุดตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้
ที่
เมืองที่ครูนิคอยู่ครับที่อเมริกา 8 โมง
37 นาทีตอนเช้าครับป่า
ขึ้นเขาเป็นตอนเช้านะคะ
แล้วที่ประเทศไทยครับที่ครูหญิงอยู่ตอน
นี้กี่โมงแล้วครับที่ประเทศไทยตอนนี้ก็
20:00 น 37 นาทีค่ะเล่นตอนกลางคืนนะตอน
กลางคืนค่ะเวลาครูหญิงเวลาครูนิคเนี่ย
ต่างกัน 12 ชั่วโมงนะคะ
ใช่สองชั่วโมง
เอาจริงๆจำง่ายนะจำง่ายเพราะตัวเลขมัน
เหมือนกันแค่กลางวันกับกลางคืนท่าทรายค่ะ
น้องก็โอเคเดี๋ยวเขาผู้หญิง - ก่อนนะคะ
พรุ่งนี้เนี่ยคุณนิดอยู่อเมริกาคุณนิอยู่
ที่บ้านใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับอยู่ที่บ้านครับ
แป๊บนะคะอยู่ที่บ้านเนาะ
เอาสีดำแล้วกันนะคะคุณนี้ก็อยู่บ้าน
ก็เลยค่ะแต่ว่าผู้หญิงน่ะอยู่กรุงเทพฯไม่
ได้อยู่บ้าน
แต่มีบ้านนะคะมีบ้านที่ไม่ได้อยู่
กรุงเทพฯบ้านเนี่ยอยู่ชลบุรีชลบุรีเนี่ย
อยู่ใกล้กรุงเทพนะ
จ้อยใกล้ๆขับรถไปน่าจะประมาณ 1 ชั่วโมง
ครึ่งในครับสายค่ะ 1 ชั่วโมงครึ่งจาก
กรุงเทพมหานครพี่เทพเกาะถึงชลบุรีแต่ถ้า
จัดกรุงเทพฯถึงบ้านครูหญิงเนี่ย
น่าจะประมาณ 2 ชั่วโมงครึ่งคิดว่าอ๋อโอเค
ตายอ้ะเดี๋ยวกูเออพวกผู้หญิงบอกว่าครู
หญิงที่กรุงเทพฯไม่ได้อยู่ที่บ้านแล้ว
อยู่ที่ไหนครับ
ไหนก็เรียกว่าบ้านแล้วนะแต่ว่าไม่ใช่เป็น
บ้านแล้วอยู่ที่ไหนอยู่คอนโดค่ะอยู่ข้าง
หน้าอกโอเคโอเค
คอนโดมิเนียมไม่ไม่มีบ้านที่กรุงเทพฯ ok
ok ได้ๆที่กรุงเทพฯอยู่อินโดแต่ตัวบ้าน
ของผู้หญิงก็มีแต่อยู่ที่ชลบุรีๆสารที่
บ้านเนี่ยก็อันนี้คุณพ่อนะคะคุณแม่ We
Are
อารมณ์สองชั่วโมงเอาไปก่อนนะคะแล้วก็ก็มี
อันนี้ครูหญิงนะคะแล้วก็น้องชายน้องชายก็
ที่บ้านที่ชลบุรีเนี่ยก็จะคุณแม่เราก็ก็
น้องชาย 2 คนเนี่ยอยู่นะคะอ่ะนี่คุณพ่อ
เพราะเสียแล้วครับผู้หญิงแหละอยู่
กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมค่ะที่บ้านครูหญิงที่
ชลบุรีเนี่ยที่บ้านคนไทยนะคะก็จะเลี้ยง
หมา
มีหมา
ที่บ้านผู้หญิงนะมีหมาเยอะมากนะคะคุณ
บิ๊กมีหมากี่ตัวครับงูค่าบ้านครูหญิง
เนี่ยน่าจะประมาณ
อีกไม่แน่ใจว่า 3 หรือ 4 ตัว
แต่ว่าคืออ่าอ่ะอยู่ใกล้ๆกันเนี่ยคือติด
กันเลยนะคะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นบ้านครูเอ๋วัน
นักเรียนรู้จักครูเอ๋นะแม่นี้ครูหญิงแล้ว
ก็ครูเอ๋เอ๋นะคะอยู่บ้านใกล้กันเดินได้ก็
คือนี้เป็นรั้วบ้านนะคะเป็นรั้วบ้านในก็
เป็นประตูประตูเข้าบ้านไอ้ก็บ้านครูเอ๋
ได้ครูเอกก็มีหมาอีกประมาณสามสี่ตัวโอ้โห
OK มีหมาเยอะมากแล้วเวลาครูหญิงเนี่ยจาก
กรุงเทพแล้วก็กลับบ้านที่ชลบุรีพอเดินถึง
บ้านก็จะได้ยินเสียงต้อนรับนะคะ
ถุงเนาะ
ใช่กูนี้พูดถูกเป็นฝูงเลยค่ะเพราะว่าหมา
เนี่ย 2 บ้านใช่ไหม 2 บ้าน 2 หลังรวมกัน
น่าจะประมาณอาทิเอาให้โหก็แล้วกัน
ก็เยอะนะเยอะค่ะเยอะบ้านคนไทยอ่ะต่าง
จังหวัดเขาก็จะชอบเลี้ยงหมา
ผู้หญิงก็มีทั้งหมาแล้วก็แมวขอ
แมวก็เยอะ
จริงๆแถวแถวบ้านคุณนิดนะที่กรุงเทพเนี่ย
ก็ก็มีหมาเยอะแต่ว่ามันจะมีทั้งหมาที่คน
หรือคนเลี้ยงแล้วก็แบบเป็นหมาจรจัดก็คือ
หมาที่เขาก็ปล่อยไว้อย่างนั้นเราก็มันก็
นอนตามถนนก็คือหมาที่ไม่มีเจ้าของของใช่
วันนักเรียนอาจจะเห็นตามแบบข้างหน้า
เซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นอย่างเงี้ยแต่ไม่เห็นมา
กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมคะจะเห็นข้างหน้าเซเว่น
อีเลฟเว่นจะมีหมานอนเยอะๆหมาจรจัดใช่เป็น
หมาจรจัดที่คือหมาที่ไม่มีเจ้าของไม่มี
บ้านอยู่แต่มันก็มีเยอะมากแล้วเอาจริงๆนะ
คุณได้จับกลัวหมา
คือเมื่อก่อนเดี๋ยวตอนเล็กๆเนี่ยกลัวมาก
คือเล่นไม่ได้เดินใกล้ๆไม่ได้เลยนะเพราะ
ว่าเคยโดนมาอาจตอนเล็กๆค่ะและที่นี้เนี่ย
พอโตขึ้นโตขึ้นก็เริ่มเปลี่ยนว่าเออหมา
ตัวเล็กๆเล่นได้ไม่เป็นไรเพราะมันสู้เรา
ไม่ได้เพราะเราโตแล้วผมคนตัวใหญ่กว่าเออ
ใช่เราตัวใหญ่แล้วเราก็ไม่กลัวที่นี้พอ
ตอนนี้ครับตอนนี้เนี่ยกลัวน้อยลงก็หมาตัว
ใหญ่เล่นได้แต่แช่คุณนี้จะไม่ชอบเวลามัน
เห่าแบบพุ่งๆแบบเนี่ยครับคือพอมันเห่า
เดี๋ยวพรุ่งนี้จะเอาแล้วมันจะทำอะไรมันจะ
กัดเราหรือเปล่าหรือมันจะสู้กันแล้วหรือ
อย่างนี้คุณนี้ก็ถ้าชอบใช่เพราะว่าถ้า
สมมติว่าอย่างครูหญิงเนี่ยก็เหมือนครูนิค
นะคะก็คือเป็นคนที่กลัวหมามากๆมากๆแล้ว
เวลาไม่ว่าหมาตัวเล็กหมาตัวใหญ่ท่าหมา
เห่าหรือว่าวิ่งเหมือนไม่ใช่ถึงจะวิ่งนะ
ครับเหมือนหมาเนี่ยว่าเป็นสัตว์ที่เวลา
มันเห็นคนท่าหมาที่ใจดีนะคะเวลาเห็นเรา
เนี่ยมันจะวิ่งเข้ามา
มันจะวิ่งกับโลกจะกระโดด
น่ารักอ่ะแต่ผู้หญิงแหละกลัวเวลาหมาเนี่ย
มันกระโดดใส่เราเอาข่าวจะรู้สึกเหมือนแบบ
เหมือนคนให้หรอกว่าเวลาเราเห็นอะไรที่เรา
กลัวเราจะขาแข็งอ่ะอ่ะนะถ้าสมัยถ้าสมมติ
ว่าเรายืนอยู่อย่างนี้ค่ะสมัยเรายืนอยู่
เนาะแล้วมันมีหมาวิ่งเข้ามาแล้วเรากลัว
เราก็จะแบบนี้เหมือนสตาร์ทเอาไว้อ่ะค่ะ
เดินอ่ะไม่ได้ใช่เพราะว่าแบบทุกอย่างแข็ง
ไม่หมดเลยใช่ทรายใส่หน้าแต่ว่าผู้หญิงอ่ะ
หมาคือท่าหมาอยู่เฉยๆไม่กลัวไม่กลัวแต่
ถ้าหมาเห่าหมาวิ่งเข้ามาเราจะรู้สึกกลัว
อาแต่จริงๆอ่ะครูหญิงก็เพราะว่าเมื่อก่อน
น่ะคุณนี้ก็กลัวแบบกลัวหมดเลยแต่ว่า
เพื่อนคุณนี้กันนะเขาบอกว่าก็ก็ให้ดูหาง
เพราะว่าถ้าหางหมามันขยับกับเมียนะเนี่ย
หาเงินมั้ยใช่ถ้าหางวันเวลามันเห็นเรา
แล้วหาไม่ขยับเนี่ยแล้วมันหมอกสายมาทำไง
มันแปลว่าหมาใจดีหมาหาอยากเล่น
ๆแต่ถ้ามันให้ลองลองหางมันนิ่งเนี่ยเรา
ว่ามันกูว่ะ
เพราะอันนั้นอ้าอย่าไปอยู่ใกล้ๆๆๆ
ว่าหมามันกลัวเรามันก็คิดเองครูหญิงจะตี
มันหรือเปล่าใช่ไหวก็เลยจะให้ดูหางว่ามัน
ขยับหรือไม่ขยับใช่เออนั่นแหละคุณดีขึ้น
อยู่จริงๆแล้วคุณนี้ก็มีเรื่องเกี่ยวกับ
หมาเล่าให้ฟังอันนี้แบบ
คุณนิดเจอใครคนนี้ก็จะเล่าให้ฟังหมดแล้ว
เป็นคนนึงคอร์ดของทุนอีกกับหมาเหรอได้ก็
คุณนี้ก็อยากรู้ว่าพ่อเขารู้เรื่องแล้ว
เนี่ยเขาจะส่งสารคุณนิดหรือเขาจะ
สมน้ำหน้าแบบหัวเราะ
ได้ค่ะพูดอีกเล่าให้ครูหญิงฟังเดี๋ยวครู
หญิงจะตอบว่ากูหญิงจะฟังแล้วเนี่ยรู้สึก
แบบงงครูนิคน่าสงสารทำงานหรือว่าสัตว์ๆ
ฮ่าๆจนหน้า
เอ่อลองดูครับก็คือเรื่องมันเกิดมานาน
แล้วประมาณ
10 ปีแล้วนะใช่ง่ายก็ตอนนั้นก็คุณนี้ทำ
งานเรา
เลิกงานละเลิกงานประมาณ 11:00 นค่ะง่า
ทุ่มแล้วก็
คุณนี้ก็ไปกินข้าวกับเพื่อนกินข้าวกับ
เพื่อนแล้วก็ตอนนั้นเนี่ยเพราะว่าคุณ
มิกซ์ทำงานที่สนามบินสุวรรณภูมิ
คุณนี้ก็ต้องหาห้องหาคอนโดเช่าแล้วก็อยู่
กันแชร์กันกับเพื่อนที่นี่ก็กินข้าวเสร็จ
ครับกินข้าวเสร็จคืนนี้ก็กำลังจะเดินเข้า
ไปในซอยเข้าไปที่คอนโดที่คุณเช่าไว้เนาะ
คืนนี้ก็เดินไปคือซอยเนี่ยมันมีหมาทุกซอย
ค่ะคุณนิว่ามันมีใช่อือแต่คือคุณนี้ก้อย
เห็นหมาตัวนี้หมามันก็เห็นคุณเล็กมาหลาย
ครั้งแล้วก็คงจะเดินไปเดินมามันเราก็ไม่
อะไร
วันนั้นเนี่ยก็ประมาณหลังเที่ยงคืนละไอ้
หมาตัวนั้นน่ะมันไม่เคยปกติและนะมันไม่
เคยออกจากบ้านแต่มาตัวนั้นวันนั้นน่ะมัน
รอดประตูแล้วมันมายืนกลาง 6 เงินเป็นมหา
ที่มีเจ้าของเหรอคะได้ใช่เดี๋ยวขอผู้หญิง
ขยายซอยหน่อยนะจะได้ว่านหมาได้
อันนี้เป็นซอยนะคะนี่คือถนน
หมามันมายืนขวางครูนี้อยู่กลางซอยเหรอใช่
ใช่
อันนี้หมานะอันนี้ครูนิคเออ
ตบคุณนี่ก็อ้าวแล้วปกติมันอยู่ในบ้านเอ๊ะ
ทำไมวันนี้มันมาข้างนอกยกหมาตัวใหญ่ไหมคะ
ก็ตัวมันเหมือนแบบขนาดแบบบางแก้วเอาก็ก็
ไม่ไม่ไม่เล็กไม่ใหญ่แต่ก็ขนาดมันก็ก็จัด
กับคนได้ดูเหมือนกันเธอก็อาจจะประมาณแบบ
สูงถ้ามองการจะสูงประมาณสัก 50 เซนได้ไหม
คะ 50  cm ให้ประมาณอันใต้เออๆใช่ก็นั่น
แหละคนนิคเห็นลัพธ์มันก็เห็นคนนี้มันก็
จองละมองเราคุยก็ไปดีแล้วหางมันไม่ขยับ
หางเพื่อนบอกเดี๋ยวเปิดที่ First  People
could บิ๊กบอกเอาแล้วทำยังไงคุณนี้ก็
พยายามแบบหมานะคุณนี้คิดว่ามันน่ารู้ว่า
ถ้าคนกลัวมันจะทำยังไงเพราะคุณนี่กับนิ่ง
เราคุณก็แบบเออเราต้องอย่าให้มันเห็นว่า
น่ากลัวแล้วก็เดินเดินเฉยๆพอทุกคนเด็ก
เดินไปใช่ไหมยิ่งเข้าใกล้มันอ้ะมันเริ่ม
แล้วมันก็
คูนี้ก็
เหมือนครูเรามันก็เฮา
พอบ้านเฮาเท่าไหร่ๆ
อุ่นคืนนี้ก็เอาแล้วเข้าคุณนี้ก็จากที่
คุณนี้ก็ครัวคุณเล็กเดินไปถึงกลางซอยแล้ว
นะอีกครึ่งห่างเจอไก่คอนโดแล้วคุณนิกะห์
วิ่งออกมาวิเคราะห์เปลี่ยน
ยืนกลับมาที่ถนนโละมันก็วิ่งตาม
ดีๆเดี๋ยวตอนวิ่งตามกูวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่ง
แล้วคุณอิศร์ล้ม
ขอบคุณอีกแบบวิ่งเราล้มเนี่ยก็เอาแล้วมัน
กัดแน่นอน
รู้ไหมว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นกูหญิงแต่พอมันเกิด
อะไรขึ้นนะคะ
พอมันเห็นคุณนิดอ่ะล้อมากมันหยุดวิ่ง
แล้วมันก็เดินเข้าบ้าน
จบ
แล้วที่ดีเพราะคุณนิคล้มแล้วอ่ะคุณนี้ก็
มีแผลไงเพราะว่าพูดดิกูยิ่งแล้วมันเลว
เร็วและอิ่มเอมพอมันล้มมันก็เหมือนกับมัน
ถูว่าคุณนี่ก็มีแผลที่ข่าวแล้วก็เหมือน
กับมีที่แขนถลอกใช่ไหมเออมันถลอกมันมี
เลือดที่ดีเนี่ยคุณดีกะก็โทรหาเพื่อน
เพราะว่าจะให้เพื่อนพาไปโรงพยาบาลไปทำแผล
Top คือคือถนนที่กรุงเทพฯในไทยอ่ะมันมัน
สกปรกอาจมันสกปรกทุกๆไม่ว่าจะในประเทศไทย
หรือที่อื่นคุณนี้กลัวมันเป็นแบบแผลมันจะ
ไม่ดีมันติดเหลือมีสิทธิ์อาเรียใช่ไหมมี
แบคทีเรียคุณนี่ 9 ก็เลยโทรไปหาเพื่อนบอก
ว่าเฮ้ย
กลับมารับไปโรงพยาบาลหน่อยเพราะว่าเมื่อ
กี้
ล้มไม่ได้บอกเพื่อนนะว่าหมากัดหมาไล่กัด
บอกว่าเดี๋ยวคุณนี่ก็บอกว่าเออเนี่ย
ล้มใช่ลบเรามันมีแผลเพื่อเออเออได้ๆ
เดี๋ยวไปรับเดี๋ยวไปรับแล้วเพื่อนก็มานะ
แล้วก็รับไปโรงพยาบาลมันก็ถามเพื่อนก็ถาม
ว่าแบบเออแล้วทำไมล้มแบบเกิดอะไรขึ้นที่
นี้ตอนเขาทำแผลเนาะคืนนี้ก็เราให้เพิ่ม
จังหวะอ๋อล้มเพราะว่าวิ่งหนีหมา
แล้วเครื่องขึ้นเลยหรอโอ้ยไม่ต้องให้มาก็
ได้แบบเนี้ยเพื่อนมันก็ดูว่าล้มแบบเหมือน
กับเป็นอาตีเหตุแบบใหญ่เนาะเออ
โอ้ยล้มเพราะหนีหมาหมาก็ไม่ได้กัดด้วยหมา
ตัวแค่นี้จะไปกลัวทำไมอ่ะใหญ่ว่าหมา
ตั้งเยอะเออกัน
เพื่อหมดอะไรวะแค่ดีก็ต้องโทรมาไปโรง
พยาบาลแล้วคือมันดับหลังเที่ยงคืนแล้วนะ
ทุกคนมันจะไปนอนกันหมดแล้วอ้ะได้
[เพลง]
เปิดก็เออคนเล่าให้ใครฝากเพราะว่า
ที่โรงพยาบาลเนี่ยเขาทำแผลใช่ไหมครับเรา
เขาพันถ้าแบบใหญ่เพราะว่าอีกวันนึงคุณนี้
ไปทำงานทุกคนก็เห็นว่าแบบรีบไปโดนอะไรมา
ทำไปมันเป็นแผนให้เยอะแบบมันมีอุบัติเหตุ
รถชนหรอหรือเกิดอะไรขึ้นพอคุณอีกบอกว่า
อ๋อแล้วก็วิ่งหนีหมา
ทุกคนก็
โอเคไปใกล้กับแยกทำงานงานไปทำงานไปทำงาน
เออจะก็เรื่องเกี่ยวกับหมาเรียกคุณนิดเจอ
รักอ่ะเออก็ไม่มีเหตุไม่มีใครเห็นใจไม่มี
ใครเห็นแล้วก็
โอ้ยน่าสงสารโอเคผู้หญิงสงสารคุณนิค่ะ
หวีมาด้วยความกลัวแล้วยังล้มอีกแล้วหมาก็
แบบแล้วก็หนีไปเออใช่คือมาพร้อมกับคงเห็น
แล้วเปล่าโอ๊ยไอ้นี่มันปล่อยมันไป
[เพลง]
ว่าอุ้ยก็คิดว่าหมาโมะคงไม่ได้คิดสกัดครู
นิคหรอกนะแต่ว่าเห็นคุณอีกวิ่งตกใจถึงไอ้
วิ่งเออใช่ๆแล้วจริงๆเพราะคืนนั้นน่ะฝน
มันตกด้วยเพื่อนกูนี้ก็เลยออกไปแบบเฮ้ย
มันคงมีอุบัติเหตุแหละที่มันดัดคลื่นหรือ
แบบอากาศมันไม่ดีเพราะเขารู้ว่าหมาแล้ว
คือหมาตัวนั้นนะเพื่อนนี้คุณนิกะห์เขาก็
เคยเห็นงานแล้วเขาก็เลยคือรับมันก็ไม่ได้
ดูนะ
มันก็ไม่ได้น่ากลัวมันก็ตัวเล็กๆเราก็
เห็นมันทุกวัน
เออเออได้ตัวดีกันได้ก็เป็นเรื่องเกี่ยว
กับหมาของคุณอีกก็ตอนนี้ครูนิคเนี่ยเล่า
ให้นักเรียนฟังแล้วใช่ไหมคะ
โค้ชใครบอกก่อนนักเรียนเนี่ยฟังแล้ว
คิดยังไงหรอคะส่งสารพรุ่งนี้โก๋กูนิเจ็บ
ไหมหรือว่า
ทำไมพรุ่งนี้หวางเพราะเออใช่อันนั้นแหละ
ครับก็คือเรื่องที่
แต่หลังจากนั้นคุณนี้ก็ไม่ค่อยกลัวหมา
แล้วนะ
สงสัยพบเพื่อนพูดเยอะแบบกลัวทำไมหมาตัว
แค่นี้พรุ่งนี้จ่ายแล้วก็แบบมีเทคนิค
กระดูหางของมันสิว่ามันมันสายไหมหรือว่า
มันนิ่งๆเฮ้ยๆแต่เราตอนนั้นน่ะเราตกใจ
แล้วเนี่ยเราก็ไม่รู้หรอกเราไม่มีเวลาที่
จะไปดูว่าเป็นยังไงเรื่อยๆ
คุณเล็กไม่เห็น
ใส่ระดับพ่อมามันหูไง
กลัวเฮ้ยเราเราก็ไม่มีเวลาหรอกพ่อมามัน
ขู่แล้วอ่ะเลยเดี๋ยวแป๊บนึงขอดูหางก่อนนะ
หมาอ๋อแล้วกลัว Beat ไม่มันไม่ได้แล้วก็
ไม่อ่ะในสมองแล้วคิดอย่างเดียวมันจะต้อง
กลับรถได้แน่ๆเลยมันจะต้องๆๆเลยไอ้หัวเรา
เนี่ยคิดแล้วนะว่าไปทางก็ได้บรรณครูบาระ
นันท์ไปได้มั้ย
เออครับเกี่ยวกับมาสายขาวเป็นเรื่อง
เกี่ยวกับหมาที่ครูติ๊กเอามาเล่าให้ฟังก็
เรียนอย่าลืมคอมเม้นนะคะว่าจะสื่อสารคลี
นิกหรือว่าจะหัวเราะครู dip  Mass ของ
เล่นไลน์แล้วเดี๋ยวกูนิคจะไปดูอะไรค่ะแต่
ว่าวันนี้วีดีโอนี้เดี๋ยวเราก็ไปก่อนนะ
แล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันในวีดีโอหน้านะคะ
ได้ๆครับ ok ไว้เจอกันใหม่คำนักเรียนไว้
เจอกันใหม่ครับครูหญิงค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ครับ